good afternoon everyone and thank you
for participating on this
call with us and we want to give you
an update on the vaccination campaign
and where we are
and as soon as today
we have a miniature about 60 000 doses
of
coffee vaccines in clark county
those vaccines have been emulated not
not only by
by the health district but also by
our partners is social day after after
county
a unb a from university
in roseman also the cities of henderson
and
unknown las vegas and other community
partners across across the county
the groups in clark county that are
illegal for the vaccine today
are the healthcare workforce who
are you know the first group that was
eligible for the vaccine
also uh i was seeing those seniors 77
years old and over
as well as our public safety and
security
workforce as including also
where a frontline community supports a
workforce
and and those groups are defined
in the state playbook for the campaign
we we also want to share with you that
even though we are offering vaccine
every day
we we receive limited supplies of
vaccines
and and based on that we plan
our delivery or services and uh
at some point it becomes so challenging
challenging to satisfy our community
demands
and the availability of vaccines are our
sites
this is something that is ongoing and
our expectation is that
in the near future it should improve or
almost improve
i also want to remind our community
that we are still fighting this pandemic
is very painful to recognize that as
today we have more than
200 residents of krakowic
that have been diagnosed with this
disease
and and we are almost almost 3000 people
who have
lost their life in god county because of
the
coronal violence so this is an ongoing
situation that we are fighting
and now we need the support from the
community
and also a for
for all of us to take advantage of the
vaccine
as soon as we are illegal and the
vaccines are
available for everybody please
go and take your shot because it will
protect you
and also we protect those around you
because
the transmission of the virus will
decrease as we
have more and more people vaccinated
against
this disease and
i would like to introduce a
councilman esco esco black he's the
chairman of our board and
spokes thank you dr lagann
uh i mentioned last week at the media
event
my appreciation and gratitude for the
individuals working diligently to help
not only with mitigating the spread of
the pandemic over the last many months
but also
importantly now the the really
challenging logistical effort we have
before us to administer the vaccine
to those within clark county that would
like to receive it and so again i just
wanted to say thank you
every day these individuals i don't
think they take a day off every day
they're meeting
discussing and formulating plans and
coordination
to really handle this tremendously
unprecedented logistical effort
having said that as we begin to offer
the vaccine to people
more people throughout the community and
more groups i'm asking
on behalf of these amazing people who
are working diligently
for your patience and and your for your
support uh for your understanding
our overarching goal as public health
professionals and as a
as a health district is to make sure
that everyone who wants a vaccine
will get one and our goal is to do that
as quickly and as safely as possible
bearing in mind that everything that we
do is contingent upon the supplies that
we have on hand
to plug into the infrastructure that
we've built so as appointments are
available
and expanded to additional groups of
people in these groups it's important
for you to know that you may not get the
first available
appointments because we're still trying
to get those that are in the most
vulnerable categories
through to an appointment and vaccinated
but again
appointments will be coming more readily
available and
anyone and everyone who wants the
vaccine will be receiving it so
again thank you so much for the team
who's helping make this happen and for
those of you
in the community again i ask for your
patience and your support as we work
together
on this uh unprecedented venture thank
you dr lagann
thank you councilman scott i would like
to introduce
a commissioner madeline patrick she is a
vice chair of our board of health
please
thank you dr lagon and i just want to
say ditto to councilman black's
appointment and i hope that the public
understands that many people
are doing this for the first time and we
are all working together to ensure that
our community is safe
you can continue to help keep us safe by
practicing the social distancing
washing the hands and the face mask
why we continue to roll out the vaccine
understand that there's no process that
is perfect
we are flexible and we are working hard
to refine our process every single day
so thank you dr lagon and joanne for you
and your teams and all of the work that
you're doing
the national guard and chief steinbach
um
i know that many of us are not sleeping
uh to ensure that we're
efficient and we're getting the vaccine
out and
we're still testing for that matter at
the same time so thank you
thank you commissioner um i would like
to introduce
a joan ru piper johann is a chief i'm an
ethical nurse
of clinical services and she has been
leading our campaign efforts joanne
please
good afternoon everyone and i just
wanted to
say that our teams are working very
diligently on getting this vaccine
out and along with clark county
and i really want to
ask for your patience we're working
through the tiers
however our appointment system
certainly isn't perfect yet and we're
working on it
we're in a much better place than we
were last week
um we have uh a better system
starting tomorrow and so
we are hoping that the public
though however does consider to to
not make appointments when uh you are
not in a certain group
so uh think about um
how we can get to our
group and those with special needs and
even our healthcare workers we're still
working on those
um groups so um
i think that's it for me okay thank you
johan uh
i will ask chief steinbeck he is one of
our
biggest partners and you know with his
leadership he's really helping us a lot
so cheaply
thank you dr again uh it's just an honor
to be able to work through this process
of course we have unknown supplies that
are coming to us and uh it's very
difficult
uh to to plan moving forward on how to
get those out
i think you're doing a very good job of
of uh of balancing that
and ccfd and all of uh all clark county
departments or
and any other cities that and and every
other industry is here to support
so um i'm here to answer any questions
but
uh unders i just want to make it clear
to everybody out there that
that the supplies coming in are are
very volatile and once we get more
stability to that
um you'll see a much smoother process
thank you
thank you okay corey would you like to
go
into the questions yes sir at this time
we will open the floor for any members
of the media to ask their questions
please be sure to use the raise hand
feature up first we have jacqueline
schultz from fox5
please go ahead good afternoon following
up on
um uh what miss rupert said uh regarding
the website improving starting tomorrow
wanted to know
what in particular that meant uh also
have a question regarding um the sites
uh
in terms of issues we've heard of
line jumpers people showing up without
appointments uh
there was someone who told me that their
senior mother was turned away yesterday
and cash
out of supplies uh if you can
address those issues as well
okay do you want you want to take the
first
part sure i'll take the first part sure
what i meant by um improving our system
we're moving to a different uh format
tomorrow
and we've been testing it at our western
site and it seems to be working well
where people will register with their
demographic information
and that will speed up the process
during the clinic and we're also
able to gather more information and send
out
reminders and those types of things
okay and the the second part of the
question i think was about
a cash man and
i'm not cheap if you have any details
into that piece
well i certainly can't speak to the
specifics of
of what was just reported i can tell you
that
we have the nevada national guard down
there
along with some ccfd fire personnel
and uh and and um other community
partners running that
site um we
want to honor appointments of course uh
and we are and we are honoring
appointments like i said the
the supply chain has been a little bit
volatile
um and uh we're working out our process
at that cashman site just like the other
sites
throughout the weeks or throughout this
last week
uh it's improving we've been pushing to
get more capacity out of that site so it
opened up at a thousand
then they pushed to 2000 um and
and our goal is to sometime get to 4 000
a day out of that site we hope i've
gotten a lot of positive feedback as to
how the site is running
there is that that is what most of
people
that are down there experience um there
are uh so so the way the vaccine and
i'm a fire chief and joanne works with
vaccines so she can explain this much
better than i can
but the way that the vaccines work is
that
you there's there's times uh associated
with the vaccines uh specifically after
you've opened up a vial
sometimes there's an opportunity there
and a desire on our part to make sure
that
none of that is wasted if that ends up
going to somebody that doesn't have a
scheduled appointment
then that's better than the uh than the
vial being wasted
but as has gotten
certainly has improved um we think that
the the people coming through there
uh without appointments and uh without
the proper uh proof that they were in
the
right category or right tier excuse me
will be extremely minimal if not totally
non-existent
so that's that's the way that we're
operating there
and we apologize to anybody that was
inconvenienced by that
and hope to get them in as soon as
possible
okay thank you our next question today
comes from mary hines
thank you um i've spoken to hundreds
of seniors heard from hundreds of
seniors
um 70 and up who haven't been able to
make appointments
i'm wondering what is the the rationale
for opening up
vaccines to so many additional groups as
you did
friday when you still
have served many members of our older
population
who are those at greatest risk
what what is the explanation
okay well the the way that we look at
this
was based on arena planning
the the the seniors that we start also
in the vaccine at our sites
is part of a combination between our
mass vaccination sites
and the vaccination opportunities that
that will be
or actually are already available
starting
today at local pharmacies i don't know
if
you if you saw the announcement from the
state that
came up yesterday that they have a
work a working and smith pharmacies
they will be offering a vaccine to the
seniors
starting today and also they provided a
link for appointment for seniors are
at those facilities so what it means is
that
starting from today the senior
senior who had the opportunity to
receive the vaccine
at local pharmacies close to the
neighborhood
in addition to what we are offering at
the master vaccination
site so it so
that's that's that's irrational for us
when we decided to open
for the seniors waiting for the the
complement from the local pharmacy that
started today and also because we
still have to support the vaccination of
the
the workforce and that's what we're
trying to accomplish
our next question today is from mr john
traynor
hi thanks guys uh just a two-part
question at this very moment how many
days worth of vaccine do you think you
have
currently in the sec for you we've had
reports
of some municipalities some cities
vaccinating their employees
can you verify if that is happening and
if so why that's allowed
okay do i want to take the first piece
the first part so the vaccine it depends
on
the demand of course so uh and the
allotments from the state so we put our
order in on tuesdays and we'll find out
tomorrow
whether what we will get next week so we
expect
our vaccine supply to be adequate
through uh monday tuesday
we can only get one week of a vaccine at
a time
right uh the the second part of that we
we are distributing vaccines to
to multiple partners in the community
including uh
local jurisdictions of cities and
and and and those partners are asked to
to i mean it's a vaccine to those groups
that that fall
within within the the lanes that we are
currently working with since the
the seniors healthcare workers
is safe in safety and uh
how we continue the group the frontline
community support
so on the on the dos great lines
all those sites are asked to operate and
that's what they have been doing
including offering vaccine to to the
seniors
at the site
next up is mr jeremy chen
hi there uh my question is
pretty much regarding since we now have
the the new body administration in place
uh the the president then now saying
that his goal is to
vaccinate uh or at least administer 100
million doses of the vaccine within the
first
uh 100 are there any sort of
needs or uh hopes uh with the
pot the likelihood of more federal
involvement in terms of how
uh the health district can roll out the
vaccine to to everyone that that needs
it
uh at this point obviously all across
the country there have been
kind of news of kind of a little bit of
a disconnect
as far as how many vaccines were
available and and whatnot so i wanted to
see
if how that would affect you know the
needs of
the health district and and the second
question is more about clarification
did you mention there's 60 000 uh so far
that have been
administered doses administered in clark
county or is that how many the
uh the health district has at this point
thank you
okay um
yeah i i said in the beginning that
there have been
is 60 000 doses a minute there in clark
county
uh and today i would say
earlier this morning the the number of
doses available
at the healthy street was i believe
about 26
26 000 roses that
my actually be gone through through the
weekend
uh regarding the new administration well
i mean we are just within minutes of the
new administration because
you know say president biden
just took office at noon eastern time
and they they have they have mentioned
plans to
to enhance the the vaccination campaign
and provide additional resources
uh this is something that again is very
early
on that process we we don't have any
specifics right now
uh locally that we could provide to you
because again
it's just the very first day of the
administration i don't know if
commissioner can put that you
want to add something to that
thank you dr lagon we are working very
close with our congressional delegation
and we do um we do we have asked
for a hundred thousand just for clark
county a week
through july so as they're working to do
that 100 million we
want to make sure we're also working
with the state
very closely and our congressional
delegation
to ensure that nevada is one of the ones
with the
the squeaky wheel trying to get more
vaccines as soon as possible
because it's a it's been great to see
that you know
over 70 percent of the people are very
interested in getting the vaccine and we
want to have as much of the vaccine as
possible
in our community so while um biden
is only been there just a few minutes um
i think on our time we've already been
working with the administration
and our congressional delegation to
ensure that we get
that we have our list in already on what
we'd like to see
and what we think our community needs
our next question today is from michael
scott davidson
hello um i had a quick question uh about
um vaccine distribution um so the
state's plan
and has called for on multiple occasions
equity in distribution of coven 19
vaccines among different populations
i'm wondering at this point what efforts
um the snhd or other local governments
that are distributing the vaccine here
in clark county
are undertaking to measure and ensure
um and kind of just keep tabs on whether
our vaccine is
distribution is equitable not only in
its uh distribution to you know the
elderly or these groups that we've
prioritized but also
um racial groups across racial groups
across different areas of town as we
know that some
have been particularly hard hit um in
in las vegas the las vegas valley alone
what's being done to
measure that equitable distribution and
kind of measure where we're at as far as
that goes
okay i will start and anybody can
follow well uh
the first thing i want to say is that
the the the number of vaccines available
in clark county is very limited i have
been very limited
and and and that's how i would say
dictated how we we approach the campaign
until today
we have been working with the local
jurisdictions in order to
to facilitate distribution of the
vaccine across
across the country not just at one
or two major sites
we and that's why we we opened
a catchment recently and we
opened a vaccination site at the high
school
here and also we opened the vaccination
site
at our main facility at 280 the capital
for the
southern nevada healthy street and then
the the city of north las vegas opened
the vacillation side and
and the same for henderson
and the the university unlv
opened a vaccination site also
and in addition to other partner that
have been offering vaccine so that's
that
is kind of an initialist
approach to it to us our intention as
as the supply of vaccines increase then
we will be able to to send out
a mobile
or strike things that will actually
be deployed to specific areas of the
community
and and we i we have been working with
with our commissioners and and also
we we recently have a
meeting with a representative of the of
the different churches across the
the county to to ask for the
the feedback and and support once
we we are ready to go deeper into the
community because so
we want to be able to to offer
that vaccine but but also more than
offering the vaccine
to receive a a positive response from
all segments of our community
and and we are asking those who are
closer to the community to to be a
active participant in the mission that
we are trying
to deliver so in other words
our strategy is to in addition to the
large
mass fascination sites deploy
the things that will be targeting
specific areas of the community
including the
the zip code that you mentioned uh
before we say we
already identified and those are sick
calls
uh heavily populated by the hispanic
community but also we
we are concerns about the you know of
the african-american
community as well in terms of of access
to the vaccine
and and willingness to receive the
vaccine so
there are multiple elements to
to this issue of concerns about
equity and we are working towards
reaching that goal
next question comes from megan messerly
hi there thanks for doing these every
week um
i wanted to ask i heard from a ride
share
worker who had made an appointment at
western high school and was
was turned away and they were told that
no right your employees could get
vaccinated
and i know you all have said you're you
are vaccinating essential public
transportation workers as part of that
frontline
community support group and under the
state's playbook they do include
taxi and rideshare employees as part of
that
essential public transportation group i
was just wondering if
that was done in error or if you all
have different
guidelines you know as far as the finer
points of who fit into some of these
categories
as far as you know who should be making
these vaccine appointments right now
well obviously uh i mean you're talking
about
about a very specific situation i
i don't have that information what i can
tell you is that
uh where our thing at those are those
places they
they try to honor as much as possible
first the appointments of people who
have appointments
and and unfold into those categories
and and and also of course the the
the issue of the age group for people
who do not fall
on any of those uh categories um
i i exactly that that particular case
i i don't have any answers for you
because i don't have that information
so as a quick follow-up
i mean is southern nevada health
district um i mean it's the plan to
adhere to the
the state's playbook including those you
know finer point categories that they
detail
in there beyond the sort of broad brush
you know essential public transportation
worker
descriptions this is marilyn
and here's what i'm oh
okay uh sorry and megan here's what i
want to tell you one understand that
we're all doing our very best
uh to be consistent and to move through
the process but remember that
we have a lot of volunteers that are
helping we have a lot of folks that are
out there there's a
high demand so we're trying to manage to
make sure that people are not standing
too long we're trying to manage that
people are coming through the line um as
quickly as possible
so are there going to be those one-offs
absolutely and
um i think that you guys recognize that
what things happen right so there are
but what we're hearing
from predominantly the 17 year old group
that they experience has been good
and that they feel comfortable and that
they know that we are working hard
i stood at cashman for about four hours
myself on sunday
and that is all of what i heard is there
one or two that maybe we
missed it or and that happens in
anything i mean
understand 2 000 people vaccines
uh in an eight-hour period that's
yeoman's work
right is there going to be those
one-offs yes um
do i wish facebook would go away for a
week because there's so much
miscommunication out there but we
are working tirelessly and as you look
at that front line list
and the front line community it is a
broad group of folks
right it is our social service workers
it's our people who are running our wic
offices it's our people that um
are out there boots on the ground every
single day
and so we are working to address as many
of those
as we can with the limited amount of
vaccine that we have
so um we're focused on the bigger
broader picture on how many of those
folks that we can and
i have talked to hundreds of
constituents
that may have got misdirected
or may have filled out five appointments
when they only meant to do
one and we are trying to balance all of
that
and every constituent that i've talked
to we've been able to resolve their
issue and we'll continue to work through
those one-offs
that happen but we really do for the
public's
good we need to focus on on the
positives of what we're doing
we are not florida where senior citizens
are waiting eight hours
in line to get a shot sure maybe they're
waiting an
hour but the process is very good for
them
they're feeling good about it we are not
other states that haven't started yet so
i really hope that all of you can focus
on some of the positives
because the last thing that we want to
do is make people believe that the
process is so awful
that they don't want to come and get
their vaccine because that does not
protect our community for the long term
and we are going to have to make some
adjustments we're not perfect and
anything that we do
we have to make adjustments so i just
we are working through as many of those
front line people
that are out there facing the community
every single day and we continue to
evaluate that list
every single day based on what's going
on as chief steinbeck told you
the amount of vaccines that we have and
so it's not our intent to turn anybody
away but at some point we want people to
have appointments
and we want them to come prepared and
there's a couple of things that i think
we're not talking about here today that
we need to
we need to encourage our seniors that if
you use a walker you
normally are in a wheelchair and you
can't stand for a long period of time or
you have a mobility scooter
please bring those so that you can be
more comfortable while we're waiting
through the process
we also need to remind people that
please book one appointment
not five across the valley um i had a
lis
where one person booked up all 10
appointments for one spot
um and that's not helpful either so
um we need to do a better job on
public messaging letting people know
that
yeah we can run tight on vaccines um
at some point we may run out which is a
good thing because then we can ask for a
lot more
um do we want people to be comfortable
and be prepared when they come
to see us absolutely and three
are we doing everything as a community
to get as much of this
into our neighborhoods to ensure that
people have
um a better chance of being protected
sorry megan i'm just as passionate about
everything that we're trying to do here
we do appreciate everyone's partition
our participation today as mentioned
earlier we are doing just one question
per media outlet and if you have any
follow-ups please reach out to the
office of communication
if you're a member of the public and
have any questions send those to snhd
public information
at snhd.org in a moment we will take a
question from telemundo for dr again but
in the meantime do we have any final
comments from anyone on our panel
all right seeing none i guess we will go
move on to our telemundo question
cynthia i'm unmuting you now oh wait
okay
one moment let's
hold on let me unmute you
okay there you go okay thank you um so i
did want to point out one thing
we clark county is going to be sending
out a news release today
with southern nevada health district you
are going to read that
cash men will we don't have any
appointment
uh for this weekend so we will be
closing cashman over the weekend we will
be refining our process
we will be getting our new system up and
running and plenty of training
so i don't want you to be caught off
guard and i don't want you to tell
people it's never coming back because it
is coming back
but um we are um you know
um we purposely didn't schedule
appointments because we want to make
sure that we can get through our new
system and be ready to go and even more
efficient
early next week so i just wanted sorry
dr lagann i just wanted to put that out
there so they weren't surprised
anybody else on the panel have anything
to say
i'll just say one thing about our
appointments that
please comment your appointed time we
are having people come
early or late and it really is important
that you come
on time and we allow a certain number of
appointments per
time frame so if you come early that
really
clogs up the system and also
as far as our staff are really working
hard to
get these processes down and like
many have said some are volunteers and
um they're learning uh as we go along
especially this first couple of weeks
so please be patient with them and be
nice to them
um they're they're trying their best
thank you